hey guys how's it going so i'm really
excited because today i'm going to be
making something extremely extra special
for you now most of you guys know that
i'm a huge fan of dunkin donuts my
sister and i actually camped out for the
grand opening of one of the stores here
in los angeles how long did we sleep
outside for 15 or 16 hours i think
we did that like that yep it happened so
they just came out with this new
sandwich it's a bacon guacamole
flatbread sandwich and it's actually
made with real guacamole with fresh
ingredients so when i saw the picture of
it hold on where's it at where's my
picture
here's my recipe i'm looking at this
piece of paper as if i'm reading it
there's no words i'm going to try to
recreate it wish me luck all right so
for my ingredients i need bacon i need
eggs and for guacamole let's see avocado
tomato onion salt lime juice cilantro
jalapeno pepper and garlic
i hope that i have all of those things
avocado trick to cutting avocado
i don't know i think there's gotta be an
easy way to do this
like do you actually use a blender to
make guacamole is that something that
you would actually use a blender for
oops
a little bit of lime juice
okay
just a little lime all right jenna's
gonna prep the eggs i'm gonna prep the
guac and i'm gonna put a flat bread into
the oven
okay
into the oven we go we just wanna do a
light blend because
i don't think we want liquid
i think it looks actually quite nice oh
it smells nice too okay i need another
pan you can microwave it what
how place on
your hair look oh we're doing that
what does it say just put it
i don't know two two pepper
cover
the bacon's cooking the bacon when the
bank is cooking it'll look better when
it's done right
whoa
looks better than the picture
okay we got our crispy bacon oh we got
our guac
this is making me want broccoli oh i
love brunch well the good news is we are
making brunch guess who serves breakfast
all day cooking donuts right we have had
many road trips where we like we're like
we're starving and we want breakfast and
like i don't know yep guess what
breakfast
okay that's gonna
oh boy
that looks actually impressive
i think there's some pepper
in the real one as well all we need is
our flat bread
it's taking forever i'm actually pretty
impressed with our skills
so far so good
all right let's just take it out because
i'm sick of waiting
holy crap jenna's on fire
oh
i didn't know how to use a fire
extinguisher i think that was are we
good
oh my god
i have never had a fire before
i've never had a fire i've never i'm so
can we just go to dunkin donuts because
this is not happening
you